i think we do remember about chase de
young in spring training he's anxious
to get out there in the mound
to start a game and he's ready to go
one major league
victory for chase de young and 15 career
appearances 10 starts and how about that
comeback
that's a comeback for you 3-0
the
tgtj graduate in kyle freeland second
start of the year
the two one from freeland we got a
swinging liner up the middle base head
kevin newman with a one out single to
center and that's his first hit against
the lefty this month
let's ground it hard up the middle the
man right behind the mound throw out
stallings at first
pitch bounce towards the left side
rogers to mcmahon for one on the first
for the double play
you know kyle freeland who knows how to
get ground ball outs
gets craig to bang into a 6-4-3 twin
kill
sure does that's a specialty of kyles
did so well a couple of years ago that's
been a trademark of his
and there's a strikeout and the second k
for deyoung
chase gets the chase
and there's a tapper how do you like
chase de young so far i'm really liking
it okay
just checking
tom at second with one ounce adam
frazier leads everybody in baseball with
67 hits again professional hitter adam's
been doing a great job this year just
staying consistent
crack toward the right center field gap
and he has done it again
and frazier headed to second base head
first dive for frasier
gives the pirates a one nothing lead
once again adam just being at him 3-1
looking to get out of this inning
sky to blackman
but not after the pirates score rockies
still have yet to score in pittsburgh
solid shot to right field
reynolds will cut it off and keep daws
at the first but the rockies with their
first hit in the ball game
he
got him
i just wanted to circle right there that
was a
big at bat right there early in the game
now it's charlie blackmon
o2 pitch swung on and this one's hit
pretty well to right center field and
that one's going to carry and one hop
the wall around third and coming in is
dazza throw over to third base is not in
time rbi triple for charlie blackmon and
the rockies finally break through
it's tied up it won
he struck him out
chase deyoung he gives up that triple to
tie it but boy he buckled down striking
out fuentes and rogers
face hit
to start things out pirates could uh
give greg a nice parting gift by coming
up with a victory because he'll be a
pirate forever
and headed up the middle just past the
shortstop rogers putting runners at
first and second
will craig
will hit into a double play
his first time up puts runners at first
and second and the pirates have the
bases loaded kai tom now
bounces this one oh what a slick play by
adams and the race to the bag safe
kai tom right in the middle of it all to
give the pirates the lead
with an infield hit and rbi and it's two
to one good job by kai tom hustling and
getting down the line right there play
was really really close so one out with
the bases full
and adam frazier coming up fourth inning
freelance sets and a one-two
swing in the ground ball got it toward
first right at the bag adams tags the
bag the
tag home safe
force play was off
craig is in with a head first dive and
the pirates lead three to one
so a base hit and now back to back walks
bases loaded nobody out for joshua
fuentes
he got him looking look at that pitch
it's a great pitch by sam howard right
there one with the fastball it's a great
pitch with a bases low to it with nobody
out there
now howard gets left on left with matt
adams two balls of two strikes here it
is adams takes strike three call
throws him on the slider
back to back strikeouts looking for sam
howard bases loaded for the rockies but
unfortunately there's two outs now it's
back-to-back strikeouts first by joshua
fuentes and then by matt adams both
looking a lot of pressure now on brendan
rogers after watching what just
transpired wow
look at that
clay holmes
that was nasty
ground ball to mack
he's able to get it spin and throw
very nice
two innings of work for jordan sheffield
popped him up
foul ground
and
frazier calls off craig at the last
moment and makes the catch
oh
well the rocky strand two
just like that rockies have two runners
on again this is the way the sixth
inning started with the base hit and
then a walk first baseman matt adams
one two
that hit him
it's like a check swing well
the home plate umpire dj rayburn said it
hit him but now he's gonna check with
field and colebrook did he swing
well adams walked straight into the
rockies dugout
so as a strikeout dead ball go back
charlie will go back to third
and he also send
joshua back to first they're the base
runners now blackman fuentes and rogers
rick faces the lefty hitting dom nunez
huh struck him out
chrome
the bases juiced
all four
[Applause]
so cj takes the walk charlie come on
home
rocky's just down one
dave maggie then giving the instructions
to ramel toppy about the new pitcher
richard rodriguez as the rockies have
added a run
fly ball
right center field and polanco is there
and the rockies get one but they leave
them loaded against rich rod
three more outs and he can
start using that broom second walk of
the day for mcmahon brings up the
rockies best hitter today and charlie
blackman
charlie drills it
did he get enough
get out of here off the wall
mcmahon's rounding third he'll come home
and charlie with his third hit ties it
up three to three
matt adams the left-handed batter now
matt adams grounds it up the middle
right past the ship matt adams comes
through
rockies take the lead off rodriguez in
the top of the ninth
they are now sitting ahead four to three
[Applause]
three two coming
swung on and missed
bart gets the save
and saves the road trip for the rockies
wow did he ever